what's happening reject nation we are
going to watch today episode 8 of star
wars visions
if you end up enjoying our video hey hit
the like button and if you don't hit the
dislike button doesn't matter
as long as you hit one of them also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the last episode of visions is up
big thanks to berthomsgen.org jaden
don't know which one write down these
highlights as always full length watch
along as we sync it with the time code
or over at our patreon page over there
we cover many shows with the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
let's do this
the people of tao grow increasingly
frustrated by imperial oppression
damn imperials
so you're one of the empire's neighbors
who managed to escape where are your
mother and father
my mother and father aren't around
anymore oh
you can join our family we have lots of
food you can eat as much as you want
you cannot say
and here i thought that everyone likes
to go on about how boxygasty little
always does the right thing besides
let's go come on thanks eric look what
you've done thanks i'll
[Music]
are you still worried
[Music]
it's all so new you're going to become a
proper family
oh no
seven years
[Applause]
[Music]
where was my sister
wow she's so grown up
i can't believe you attacked the
imperial family it is the empire who
polluted our sea and in village dowl
ocho and you too father please stop
there's no reason for you both eat us
without the help of the empire we will
have no chance to make any progress the
empire provides for us and offer support
here comes support
why can't you at least try to understand
sorry boss
[Applause]
like normally the rules are reversed
yeah like other mediums
we have a duty that's been passed down
for generations we need not capitulate
to the empire and the kind you need to
open your eyes i've got a bad feeling
about this
even though i'm originally from a
different planet i've come to feel at
home here
so i kind of understand what father is
saying
i get it you know i love this planet and
i love papa too papa doesn't get it
but leave it to me
i know how to take care of the household
don't drink the kool-aid come on ocho
i've been waiting for you ocho oh joe do
you know this guy
i can't leave it up to papa anymore
as a successor i will persuade him
and if i can't i will force papa to stop
why not come with us to help with our
redevelopment initiative trust me think
about this ocho you know who would break
father's heart
this is the way to do oh
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's a kyber crystal
father where did everybody go most of
them up and run away
about that
she's taken the empire side and they
said if she couldn't stop you they were
gonna make life hard for our clan i want
the three of us to live together again
i mean i i want to put a stop to the
empire's oppression and i want ocho to
come home too so father blend me your
strength
you have a good heart dump
she's your blood daughter
yeah
i get it
[Music]
keep this sword close to your heart
i'll respectfully accept
now it's off to fight the empire i know
that ocho loves you father she told me
so herself
i'm glad to hear that oh so exasperated
[Laughter]
oh god did it just happen uh i was just
joking
that's a feeling that means the boss is
in trouble
oh bad feeling
punch it
oh [ __ ] this episode might be my
favorite music so far
awesome
nice what a sick weapon
oh
look at that actual blades whoa
i'm sorry but you don't understand
yes i do and i have since the first time
i looked into your eyes
i'm your father and you're my little
girl
oh please just come home
i got sweet gig with the empire now gave
me my own robes
ah crap
sorry papa this isn't how i wanted this
to happen you have to stop your sister
please save
that's what a family does for each other
in difficult times this has nothing to
do with her i'm your daughter she's not
even a part of this family
oh ho ho
if you truly believe that then i failed
you as a father
[Music]
so grumpy
look at yourself
there is so much that matters more
oh yeah go for it come on look
oh so you and i are sisters why don't we
go home with the three of us together we
can rebuild this family
what
is
[Music]
no
[Music]
i'll bring you back
i won't give up
[Music]
i don't think so
[Laughter]
classic
guess they didn't we're going to become
a property
proper families just experience that
level of dysfunction and conflict all
right john it's all you
i thought this was really beautiful i
liked that it
built to a place
of uncertainty played a bit on your
expectations of where a star wars story
might go but in i think proportion to
its run time
it wound up in a place that was more
challenging and a bit more harsh and
heartbreaking
than i think some of the previous
episodes have gone for which i really
appreciated uh and also too just
again the way they drew
the aura of this world and the way they
focused in on the conflict you know
really kind of at least diving into
yeah within the microcosm of this family
but also the kind of leadership of this
place you know the breakdown of why or
why not to trust the empire i thought
they made a whole lot of really great
stuff out of this and made you know
something that had two kind of central
characters but also felt a bit like a
little ensemble as well so i thought it
was quite beautiful and uh as you said
probably some of the best uh
soundtracking front to back so far did
say these words yeah yeah so i thought
this was a really quite terrific what
did you think sir terrible awful episode
yeah never want to watch this show again
ah
i liked it i liked it quite a bit uh
i do wish it was longer
i thought it moved a little too quick
and i don't really have that complaint
even though some of these episodes are
shorter and this is actually one of the
longer runtime ones i do wish it was
like a few minutes longer because
some of the emotional beats were just
not hitting for me in the way how i
would have preferred them to hit for me
uh only because of the fact of how quick
it was kind of escalating because you're
sort of digesting so much information
really fast for what you get in this
slice i thought it was
it was compelling enough you know it was
it was good enough i like
this uh theme about family and family is
jesus john you're so selfish you know
when i have the arm rest i lowered them
for you i'm sorry and you just don't
ever consider
oh i didn't know they were hurting your
arms i thought it was like a clashing of
like oh if my friends that used to have
arm rests and so i thought they were the
arm rests were clashing
and this one doesn't have armor i'm
saying i'm immobile on my left arm i
didn't know that i thought it was about
the arms battling the supremacy what are
you talking about like the other chair
when you had the arms on when we both
had arms i thought it was a thing of
like oh my arms are high enough that
they're kind of clashing and it's making
our seats all messed up and now i know
that it's affecting your mobility of
gesture and now it's totally different
thing now i'm going to keep these as low
as possible you're like oh legs spread
arms out and i'm like
right here sorry you take up all the
space in the world that's where you are
you are the empire in my planet just
taking up space john i'm gonna clasp
these oh don't go don't go victim now
[ __ ]
all right here we go i'll put my foot up
here too
there you go embrace it
my evil is just intense relaxation
god the most lazy droids the most lazy
troopers
uh yeah i mean i thought the animation
is some of my favorite it feels
incredibly like the
the kind of like the ghost in the shell
cowboy bebop
sort of
that level of sci-fi anime then i'm a
little bit more accustomed to the ones
that i i grew up on so i loved how that
like where the backgrounds kind of look
like matte paintings you know and that i
really love that aesthetic
and i feel like i just transitioned back
into the episode didn't i and
uh yeah the the themes about like family
is the kind of the uh association you
have towards it i didn't realize how
much the dad did not accept
ocha ocho wait no ocho is which one ocho
is his actual daughter oh shows the
actual lop
is that yeah
think bunny lop yeah that's how you
doing
yeah so lola
what he was she she was cool
and i want to know i'm not familiar with
that star wars creature i'll see look i
can move my arms now what are you doing
look at you hey let me get you so happy
you guys can't see but right away oh
yeah i try to move
yeah no this is a great
this is a very informative illustration
because the second you did that i was
like oh yeah bang bonk i i feel it
i think actually
if i may borrow a piece of intel from
that interview we did i believe
lop is a newly configured creature for
this
series a bunny yep
you know kind of like tales from sonic
the hedgehog a little bit
but you know i think they said they
thought it would be fun to you know
create a new species and and have a
character of that variety in here too so
uh unless somebody knows much better
than me which all of you watching do but
i believe that's what
they said she has a little bunny arc
here yeah starts off cute and adorable
turned into a hot bunny yeah she hops on
up into that adult bracket funny she's
like lola bunny
in star wars that is what i've said
oh did you do you say lola bunny
specifically did you call her lola at
one point
and uh
this is the best review of all the
episodes oh don't worry guys it's only
going to get worse
so
uh
yeah we haven't
been focused here uh
what i really did like is you you get a
reason a real good argument for why
someone might be drawn to the empire
because of industrialism and well that's
explored a lot quite in clone wars of
of uh look we can have jobs and [ __ ] you
know empire's got resources
yeah
they've got networking opportunities
throughout the galaxy we can grow yeah
that's explaining bad batch continues
that um and there's rebels yeah all the
anime stuff does explore that uh quite a
bit but here i thought like it was
interesting of how it tore a family
apart like the you really get the vibe
that uh ocho is is on a
uh like she went like full dark slide by
the end yeah but prior to that i was
like i think she's just a little
misguided yeah i think this is being
sold here on you know corporate
overlords yeah
disney
she bought the did she listen to the
mouse and bought that kool-aid yeah i
think she was just uh
that's what i i liked the gray area of
that discussion and while i thought the
the the landscapes and the action scenes
were really cool to behold uh yeah i was
kind of moving by a little a little
quick but that's fair i think you could
you could have maybe done more to uh
no
no just you be good cop ip bad cop
bad cop meaning mild criticism good cop
meaning all the love but all the
comments will be about the disagreements
with my my criticism hey that's driving
engagement and that's more important
that's more important than anything else
more important engagement content yeah
uh yeah
so what are you gonna say
what could have they done john i mean
because of how it's i think when you get
to the end and this and they have the
actual showdown between lop and papa and
ocho and all that uh
a little more
something or other i'm not even sure how
it would work because i think a lot of
this is just tied to lop's perspective
or or always involving that but maybe
some other scene or moment with ocho so
we can see kind of her internal side of
this because when she comes back
and at the time even at the turn i don't
know
it depends on how you read that moment
at the bridge if that's like a reveal or
if that's more of just like the next
step of her character evolution because
by the time she gets back it's like oh
wow you're full on dark side you got a
whole new outfit you know like yeah you
know you seem like a hundred percent on
the empire train in a different fashion
and so
i think maybe they could have finessed
the more interest you know it's it's
more interesting when they're in the
cruiser together and they're discussing
it just as sisters you know there are
parts about this episode that remind me
of
uh the planet early on in my favorite
star wars movie solo star story i know
you're gonna say that yeah so they have
elements there
and uh i
i did like i like i like the uh
i guess i think some of the dialogue
could have been a little bit more
very once
yeah because some of a lot of it was
just like
we're family we're family
essentially what a lot of the
i thought there was like a really good
debate posed yeah when they when the
when the father and daughter are at odds
because i like the juxtaposition of when
you have
like hey buddy girl join our family you
rock and he's like shut the hell up i'll
beat you in public no one will care
and then it cuts to seven years later
and they're at odds yeah and bunny girl
gets uh uh uh
lop
bunny lop gets along better with
daddy and
ocho does not
and i liked uh i like the empire's
ambassador that they had here
like 2013 max landis
my god yes
and clearly evil
that's the other thing too i was like
this guy talks evil like well the empire
is is filled with the dark side as and
and a lot of times it's very as
established in some of these other
episodes it's a very insidious feeling
something you can't see
but it's a feeling that can consume you
and as because like there are things
here that i wish
like a little bit of breathing room
would have helped out a little more
especially like she just learns about
the lightsaber and i like the history of
the sand i like how this felt like japan
in the future in a like a a struggling
part of the world you know future feudal
japan yeah yeah yeah so i liked having
that quality
but yeah like she learns about the
lightsaber you get this history of and i
like all that i like the ingredients and
overall i really i'm not just saying
overall i really did enjoy the episode
um but yeah then she uses like the force
and and she's like freaking crazy
awesome with the lightsaber
and could have been maybe a another act
in the middle of her receiving it and
having that ceremony to just full-on
battle now
yeah yeah and but i do like that it ends
on a on a darker note where
it's it's like kind of ironic how
she was the one saying come join the
family
and then now it ends with her leaving
the family and then he she's more like a
daughter
to him yeah now
so
which is a nice i think that's a neat
twist on because so many of these have
had like very star warsy themes and you
know family found family
uh and the kind of
divides that can become of you know
something like who sides with the empire
and why i i appreciated that this one
took that at least and left it at a
darker place where it's like lop is
determined or her goal
is to bring this family back together
somehow i don't even think that's
probably
an option any longer with the way her
sister has gone but i i appreciated that
it's yeah like the hardest version of
that it's not
necessarily letting you revel in the
found family so much as it is like the
anguish of trying to hold one together
and i thought that was a nice
touch
you sound so stupid you talk dude just
like
you know when they wave the laser swords
so awesome yeah
wicked awesome yeah so cool yeah dude
just like supes perf yeah
dude like subscribe hit that
notification bell for
yeah who just get all the powers right
away in fact no content
should be called mary sue and mary sue
yeah star wars
guys
john said all the right things no
no
you said all the right things in the
comments
that's true
customer is always right
yeah they paid one
you invested your time
all right and maybe you watched a
mid-roll
so that's enough for me to say thanks
[Music]
you